orange is the new book as you know
parole is a privilege just because
Ocean's eleven began with the
protagonist parole hearing doesn't mean
you got to make the all-female spin-off
do the same thing does everything need
to be nostalgia and parallels when
filming in New York never pass up the
opportunity to give us one of those
overhead helicopter shots of the city
Hollywood I bet I could make a whole
feature-length film called overhead porn
title sounds dirty but the contents are
boring hey my name is Monica there
anything else I can do for you I've
never known the hotel clerk to tell you
other name when checking out but
apparently that's this hotels policy and
Debbie uses it to her advantage I mean
she could have just glanced at her
nametag and it would have been the same
thing right and instead of saying some
horrible airport hotel we were hoping
that maybe we could get our original
room back Debbie is able to steal a room
using the previous tenants information
without the clerk asking if she wants to
use the credit card on file or how long
she plans to stay you better be in there
whether he is or isn't can someone tell
me his actual life span because I swear
it said 1963 to 2018 just a second ago
and now it says 1958 to 2017 so either
someone in the continuity department
needs to be fired or the oceans
franchise is setting up some ghost
conman spin-off because George Clooney's
right-hand man was Brad Pitt it was only
natural for the other half of gravity to
pick the other half of Benjamin Button
to be hers is it just me or are these
windshield wipers on to highest setting
for wiping off what appears to be
exactly zero amounts of rain Claude
Becker Claude Becker Claude Becker also
since when does GQ ever write this much
about a person underneath their name and
with article teasers this hard to read
on the cover and compounded of past both
the bank stays to town is amazing yeah
we got lucky won't be the last time but
before we start believing this plan can
work even with luck think about the
monstrous hurdles they need to jump to
even start this heist the first hurdle
finding a fading fashion designer who
was not only desperate but is also still
good friends with Anna Wintour who will
somehow convince a hot Hollywood actress
to wear her designs a jeweler's loupe
like this one is used for examining
stones between 2 and 10 inches from the
face there's no way a focal range on
this would see anything as far away as
across the street how long would it take
you to make
a piece of jewelry of the stones ready
cut I guess we also are concerned about
any ear witnesses on this extremely
crowded Street for being so precise w
sure does leave a lot of chance like as
if the F train is any worse than any
other train you could take if you're
going through Manhattan on the F train
route your other choices are usually the
B D or M trains and those aren't any
better or worse wait BD m sorry say this
looks like you're just getting effed
name ball which real name eight-ball we
use real names around here this is some
sort of anti reservoir dogs' by us or
something that's when we get it yes
what's it because a nervous non
professional is exactly the kind of
person you would pronoun game in this
situation instead of running her through
the details
I get that cloning a pit or having fun
with daemon here wait for helping us
with the feline rescue project
apparently all it takes to get a meeting
with the hot celebrity is to donate to
their charity and they'll come to meet
you at a swanky restaurant at a moment's
notice just in time to move a jewel
heist plot along ok she's dressing her
anyway
I think page six just because Penelope
Stern is rumored to be using ROS to
dress her for the ball Daphne gets
jealous enough to track her down as if
someone like Daphne wouldn't then try to
find someone way better than ROS to
one-up her so-called rival do you want
me to set up a meeting I love Anne
Hathaway put her in all the things I set
all the things I know a real one you
know you know what I mean is it the
usual practice of pickpockets to admire
their stolen goods with a bunch of
people standing around him gets notice
to her gets ignored and for once we want
to be ignored setting aside that we
weren't even really asking for an
explanation as to why the whole team is
made up of women
isn't this the opposite of true when it
comes to the Met Gala aren't all eyes on
the women while every single male is
wearing the same black tux with very few
distinguishing features seriously what
she even mean by this just how exactly
does Tammy have Debbie's current number
on her phone Debbie's been in jail for
five years so unless she's been paying
her phone bills all that time this
caller ID is a lie sweetheart I will be
right there
little kid wouldn't immediately run over
to where her mom is as soon as she said
something not that it would really
matter since this kid has no idea what
Debbie's presence even means but this
movie is trying to make us think it does
we would like to present you all with a
hypothetical situation and we'd like to
do it with a high-tech expositional
PowerPoint that includes full video
graphic overlay and animations because
our evidence trail just isn't quite long
enough yet considered to be one of the
most exclusive
most the most exclusive party invitation
in America really I'm calling out
Sandra's bollocks here how can you be
sure that there aren't any more
exclusive parties you don't even know
about I mean me and my college roommates
through a super Bomberman tournament for
just our closest friends in 1995 and
only seven people knew about that so
nice try ladies you just tell me one dev
for a MetroCard that's it how about this
we steal fifty million dollars I'll buy
everybody MetroCard
yeah that's funny at all but Constance
needs the MetroCard before you steal all
that money so what's the freaking point
besides this Constance or anyone else
not have enough money to pay for a
monthly MetroCard why not ask Lou who's
debbie the last word on Metro cards
maybe just um I said uh whores
Oh feel me my fault good grief
the whole reason why Cartier allows Rose
to look at the Tucson is because she
speaks French to them and appeals to
their ego in some stupid way the whole
reason they're being stubborn is for
good reason the piece would require any
new insurance policy and a security team
but now that somebody knows how to speak
French to them they forget all that
Wow what a technological wonder glasses
with crystal clear heads-up display
where the lenses somehow disguise all
the graphics from everyone else in the
room so you get a two-way mirror and a
computer screen all in one not to
mention being able to sustain VR levels
of clarity with this tech so close to
your eyes this is some BS tact
she must have this son this works oh
come on
some of these glasses create a perfect
AR overlay so you know exactly which
parts have been scammed up a hell movie
simple percentages aren't good enough
for you anymore also considering this
necklace is completely symmetrical
couldn't you just have scanned half of
it and saved yourself some of the
precious time from this completely
manufactured tension look I'm all for
these pair of glasses that can scan
images and send those images over Wi-Fi
I just don't know why it would take this
long to do it considering these classes
are already do perfect what's one more
thing thank you are you gonna light up
the sky good God and how the way steals
this movie a difficult feat with so many
great actors I'm gonna remove one
another Hathaway sit if you like him you
go right and if you don't I don't I mean
Kaling and discount Evian here are truly
hilarious but is there anyone under the
age of 40 who doesn't know how tender
works even if they've never used it
before Oh Hollywood is remaking famous
paintings now the museum's agreement
with your father so let me get this
straight he planted a painting in the
museum so they would have the Sookie
the meeting that you could buck and
somehow you not only knew exactly when
they would call the meeting but where
also you decided to wait until the
meeting had already started to place the
bug rather than doing it at a less
conspicuous time moving a camera mm-hmm
it bit 1012 these how long did it take
you to figure all this out there is no
way that Debbie while in prison knew
about the camera just outside of the
bathroom at the met and she definitely
didn't know how long it would take to
move the camera so that it made an
effective blind spot I don't care if she
did win an Oscar for the Blind Side well
that was easy
also once again the oceans crew gets
lucky because the person who works at an
important place is a moron why does the
video window have a JPEG file extension
couldn't be some sort of video file
extension instead and considering its a
live feed why is it a filename at all
instead of some sort of network address
well you certainly seem qualified this
plan has too many moving parts now they
have to get Tammy hired at Vogue so that
she can arrange the seating chart at the
gala to their liking they had to somehow
give their previous coordinator chiggers
of all things and have vogue so
desperate that they hired Tammy on the
spot and have Anna Wintour so
preoccupied with a tennis match that the
hire takes place immediately but don't
worry I'm sure Debbie thought about all
this while in prison you have that
interview for the Mets top position do
it hey pointless Anna Wintour cameo /
roger federer joke is sure to confuse at
least 99 percent of the audience Taylor
Shaw white that's racist his publicist
was into it I barely hit her ass so wait
a minute how do they invite Claude
Becker whom is Debbie's ex-boyfriend to
come to the gala and somehow sweep
Daphne off her feet and instantly become
her date this is well before Daphne is
even in on it so what if she didn't like
Claude Becker what if you happen to be
dating someone at the time this is yet
another thing Debbie couldn't have known
when she planned this in prison you
better tell me this it's not what I
think it is what Claude Becker geez how
paint by oceans is this movie gonna be
to seek loo knock and pitch yet having
the exact same conversation as in 11:00
is making me wonder why they didn't just
go full psycho remake route and shop or
shot the whole thing throughout this
entire film expert hacker 9-ball does a
whole bunch of stuff in public that well
I'm not saying they necessarily get
caught significantly raises the danger
of them getting caught these are the
crown jewels from eight Royal families
of Europe
that's probably why there's mote mote
shadowing
let me just see so how does it work
there is no way that phone is taking
video of that necklace problem with
Mouse
I guess Rose is only sending her
messages to Lou it's almost like this
movie realized it was wasting cate
blanchett and needed to give her
something anything to give her more
screen time so it seems like they use
Polly magnets and a spring why in the
world is Veronica I need to check all
this stuff out and give updates on this
loud-ass subway train
also convenient magnet expert sister is
a magnet expert I mean her sister
I mean convenient hey Anne Hathaway and
Katie Holmes are here did someone forget
to invite maggie gyllenhaal considering
there were several people in this
bathroom I'm pretty sure discount to
sunny here would have been noticed
almost immediately also how convenient
that women at high society events only
use the restroom for non toilet related
activities because she didn't even
glance to see if any of these stalls
were occupied in the first place come on
like security wouldn't have had a plan
in case daphne needed to go to the
bathroom this is supposedly the best
security in the world trusted to guard
the pope but fire on the amazon here is
gonna stop them from walking in all my
ladies still in the dark
but are they though and as much of a big
deal as they make out of this bathroom
blind spot it really doesn't do anything
other than hide the actual handoff right
I mean known criminal Debbie ocean is
seen entering the area right before the
vomiting episode she single-handedly
keeps security from entering and they
know this is when it went missing it
doesn't take Sherlock Holmes to piece
this together in fact I'm not even sure
Katie Holmes wouldn't figured it out and
did Marcia Clark just break the security
camera fourth wall and shrug they do
realize they're committing an actual
crime right it's not even like the
stupid necklaces even hidden very well
on the tray sure it's possible that the
busboy would have been too distracted to
see it but you know what else is
possible about a gazillion other
scenarios where someone spots this
necklace before the ladies of larceny
take care of it good God
hold the priceless jewels out in the
open for a really long time I don't yet
your attention before I've even hidden
this stolen merchandise these seriously
may be the lousy estai stirs that ever
heist at a heist let's ignore the fact
that somehow all this would have had to
have been planted in this bathroom and
organized like this at some point before
let's even grant them for some reason no
one needed to change a baby or use that
machine or even accidentally found it
since then tell me this how does she
remove all of this evidence when she
leaves holy is that a camera in the
kitchen directly looking at the sink
where amita held up the necklace how is
it Mita not in all the trouble after
this thing is over this supposedly tense
moment is decidedly less tense when you
think about how this door should be
locked and there's no way this
independent security detail got the keys
to every door in the museum what the
hell in the water as if it just
magically disabled the magnetic clasp
and flung off her neck I'll show you
might be asking why they didn't just put
the fake necklace on Daphne in the
bathroom and avoid all this bullshit
well it's because they needed the room
evacuated while the remaining crew was
pulling off yet another heist that will
be explained later the problem is how
much money do you need you were going to
walk away with a boatload of cash after
you steal this necklace even with a loss
of what it will take to frame
jean-claude van dump this thing right
here nearly screws up both operations
all because that amount of money is not
enough also speaking of that fancy
magnetic clasp has anyone noticed that
this fake replacement doesn't have one
considering it was a last-second thing
and magic magnet sister-girl
only brought them an unlocking tool
there's no way they would have had time
to put one on the decoy it's like the
security and the criminals are having a
dumbassery contest it should be noted
that Amita did not unlock this door
before opening it when she clearly
locked it earlier and don't give me that
she had to help Cate Blanchet later
stuff because you know she would have
locked that door once she was done
Constance gives everybody their share of
the diamonds and for the most part it's
a slick passing of the baton through the
gala floor except when she gives Rose
hers where the diamonds are in full view
of any camera watching why did they even
need to hand off the diamonds now anyway
[Music]
of the many parts of this plan that
strain credulity the idea that after a
long-term relationship with this woman
that he wouldn't recognize her because
she put on an accent and a new hair
color is probably the strangest I'm
sorry but I have to take this
opportunity to rant a bit more about the
camera problem we've established that
the only place the cameras can't see is
a small spot by the bathrooms created by
9-ball which means there is now recorded
evidence of every single one of the team
doing everything else they did hiding in
the bathrooms check placing the necklace
check entering the ball looking like
Rihanna after the lockdown already
happened check and now they're all
leaving the ball in a different state
than they came in sure for some of them
it's just extra jewelry but
others are on camera as kitchen staff
and now leaving us fancy-schmancy guests
but good thing they created that little
camera shelter and everything Qumu be
first of all I'm not a member of law
enforcement I work with the insurance
carrier huh luckily for the entire ocean
screw law enforcement never gets
involved in the heist of a necklace
valued at 150 million just James Corden
because Jimmy Fallon wasn't available I
guess it was my week hilarious
misunderstanding that would in no way
happen whatsoever if John introduced
himself as an insurance investigator and
what he was here for which he surely did
before this interview even started his
ever son you two were alone while you
were wearing the necklace not picture
the security guys for some reason and
when did they have time for this you
guys are it's a fun little twist and
everything and nice pg-13 placement as
well but I'm still a little shaky on the
details here her explanation seems to
indicate that petty Kluger here didn't
finally put all the pieces together
until she was interrogated so how did
she even find the oceans crew after that
excuse me you are trespassing oh we
asked her to come and didn't tell you
guys for some reason we think it's
better that not only is the audience
surprised but our entire team is too and
I almost never throw up this is Daphne's
explanation for how she knew something
was up the whole time but it's still
kind of amazing she didn't freak out
when the necklace was stolen she didn't
know who's behind it until she was
interviewed by the insurance guy so just
because she knew something was up
doesn't mean she'd be so calm about it
like she knew she was gonna befriend
these people later and last but not
least I never forget a face so what are
you part of the IMF or something do you
scan the room for faces so you can tell
Kittredge you saw the other IMF team the
waiter was standing behind Hannah at the
top of the stairs bowtie 12 o'clock his
name is John Frazier
you know him yes he busted my father
twice my brother wants his family so
because he busted Debbie's father twice
and her brother once
he just likes you or something also is
this the only guy who does insurance
investigation how the hell does he
manage to run into the same people
committing crimes over and over and that
just happened to be related boyfriend
yep they were gonna be looking for
somebody
Debbie's plan also requires the
professional con man Claude Becker
doesn't notice heavy diamonds being
slipped into his coat pocket or that he
would notice them at any time when he
got home or gave the coat to somebody to
be dry-cleaned
don't have that any close female
friendships you're becoming a criminal
because you're lonely
tam-tam would be excellent at cinema
sets it's not just Pro fades revenge
it's a twofer yeah and Debbie Does
callous here is for some reason being
very transparent with you about framing
her ex because she trusts you I guess
but in what world is an insurance
adjustor the final say on a criminal
investigation are the police not doing
their own investigation is he not
worried about being an accessory to the
whole thing he friends you you frame him
scores are settled I'm just the courier
all is right with the world it's
brilliant it's at this point that I wish
Debbie and the rest had just gotten away
with it this little epilogue or whatever
the hell it is drags the movie right
down it asks you to swallow a lot just
because you want Debbie to get away with
it
Debbie apparently knew that John Fraser
would be conducting an insurance
investigation but she did not know
Daphne would figure out the plan and
went to help them so what was the plan
to frame Claude if Daphne wasn't in on
it you know what time for 20 extra sins
for all the things Debbie couldn't have
known when she planned this this totally
means that she slept with him after
obtaining the evidence doesn't it damn
girl why would you just steal one
necklace when you could steal one the
thing about this final hice prevail is
that it's about something we have zero
investment in sure you wanted to keep it
as a final twist from both us and the
rest of the gals for some reason but we
never felt any of the tension or joy of
the job because we didn't even know
about it until after it was over it had
absolutely very little to do with the
heist that we thought we cared about and
makes this final reveal feel unnecessary
and anticlimactic
also there's absolutely no reason why
the rest of the crew wasn't in on this
from the beginning
I guess it's fun to spring surprises on
your criminal buddies and what's more
she didn't even show them the other
necklaces until someone told her the
math didn't add up for everyone Cher I
spent a lot of time in gangs and someone
would have got shot for that also also
this might have been good information
for 9-ball to know considering she was
the one looking at the security monitors
the whole time and helping them out with
certain issues like when the security
shows up Amazon sells these 20-foot
selfie sticks all they saw was a quick
little blur damn it movie just when I
think I'm done talking about the cameras
you pull me back in does no one remember
these cameras are recording everything a
quick little blur where the cameras not
on while you were setting up this ruse
even if there are only two cameras in
this highly important room wouldn't the
one camera have a shot of you trying to
fool the other camera not to mention
there's no way to get that equipment in
either camera without the camera first
seeing you plus there are other cameras
watching you enter the room leave the
room
we distract security outside the room
there's so many cameras camera ring the
camera cameras the camera camera camera
count also you needed to have an
existing picture from this angle to pull
this off so when did you guys get one
and since when two iPhones display full
screen still photos when the actual
camera is on I see a number of times
where Yin probably tripped the alarm on
this thing but who cares it's fun right
also did they pay yen a discount rate to
do all this because remember they're
still dividing all of the money by 8 so
I guess Yin did this for a couple grand
maybe I won't have to organise his event
once again this prevents a guard from
seeing anything I think I should add
about 20 cents for the realisation that
almost every aspect of this plant from
its inception to its execution probably
would have ended up failing look at me
fellows I'm handing out wings and look
I'm not done after that necklace got
stolen security would have done a whole
sweep of the area to make sure there
wasn't anyone unaccounted for inside now
so I skipped this important wing of the
museum there is no way at the speed this
toy boat is moving that Lu had time to
exchange every single one of these jewel
pieces back and forth the Lou Diamond
physics just wouldn't work but wait
wasn't a meet up busy taking diamonds
off that necklace the whole time this
other heist was going on when did she
have time for this also did Mindy
project really have to stop her
jewellery assembly job to join Lou on
the trip to this truck just to open one
door and shut another one she couldn't
take care of that herself you know it's
great when your team of thieves can hop
onto a train without anyone else on it
so you can get an awesome group shot
without any other assholes blocking the
frame
I was just wondering how many cameras
you got there in that town somewhere in
the vicinity of 5,000
oh that's a lot of cameras nice watch
it's my brother's five long years he
wore this watch up his ass then he died
of dysentery while landing his launches
the same thing didn't you learn about
that it's rainy spectacular great big
blingy big old Liz Taylor jewels that
are locked in about 50 feet underground
you ought to be free I do not deny that
my heart has greatly desired this how
long is it gonna take us to build a
nine-foot blind spot Tony here's your
quarterback all right you protect his
blindside when you look at him you think
of me now that looks like a fast dog is
that faster than a greyhound you put him
in a race who would come in first you
had a little jockey on him
cheers Cheers babe I'll be right back
I'll be right something man you can't be
I have gel in my hair I haven't slept
all night I'm starved and I'm armed
don't mess with me